be ready Rick oh yeah your male
encountered in no could I I kind of have
a thing where I counted in okay counted
in Rick 1413 okay everybody welcome to
another episode of
[Music]
and as always we got the singing mic
[Music]
[Music]
we on the ripple recruitment is
different dripping in the sea but never
stop with the bitching and never stop
what you miss you gotta pushing to come
in and frickin drop in the grow all
right or the comedian but just the dude
that lives at home oh my god right oh
this this podcast would have already
blown up but yeah but now for good
reasons because people would be like
have you seen the lowers [ __ ] I get mad
at her mom I told you I'm doing my
podcast you got a cast somebody to be
your mom you know what actually let's do
this real quick could you play that here
huh no I'm gonna comment I'm gonna come
in as your Z's don't I'm gonna come in
as your dad all right oh god this is
what you have to deal with when you
bring people on the podcast guys you
know they're mean all right so welcome
to another and we're doing the intro
again
[Music]
so let me get this straight you came
prepared with a moustache truth be told
I always have a moustache you had a
moustache ready to go yeah I use a
moustache in my act
so you never know when you remember that
now actually net you know what I'm not
as mad about it now put your heart and
soul into your visit I'd like to do it
again and I have the glasses it's like
yeah we've missed me off oh man I'm so
sick that's that's like the main joke
that people do all the time hey I hate
when people have like a particular joke
about you that like they think you've
never heard before so that's my thing
have a big nose or wear glasses I have a
moustache so people think they're so
[ __ ] original when they go uh-huh
just a nose in the glasses come off you
know like the thing and I'm like oh
never heard that before
yes oh people haha you like my candles
oh I do like you candle that's why I was
telling you move up see if you can move
back there you go right because that
starts to tilt it'll just drive the OCD
people absolutely bananas like anytime
sums a little off
that's all they focus on in the chat for
a [ __ ] the whole episode well let's
light the candles I was gonna say that
she liked the candles and see uh-oh I
gotta like wonder that what was that
noise you got turn turn the sound off
your computer oh god I know press the
mute button I know it's fine
let me do it actually I'll do it hold on
you're gonna do things your own way but
I think it was a miss for us not to be
able to play that father-son scene out
yeah I know your judgement in my choices
got in the way of a fun [ __ ] and let
that be a lesson for the rest of your
guests no I've had Jeremiah came on you
know you you know Jeremiah Watkins you
smell [ __ ] bribe feminist Stacy wig
and all kind of stuff it was a nightmare
was fun no yeah of course yeah but you
didn't really put it he had a wig it was
like a big effort your mustache was
coming off your face anyway this is like
oh my god I wish I remembered the guy's
name right now I'm so sorry you know
what I have it on Instagram I'm gonna go
to Instagram right now because I want to
get the guy's name right no no I want to
get I could put it on the screen but I
want to say his name you know the from
the from the candle company that sent me
this where is it there B is yes hang
over a candle company really not rogue
farms no no hand hang over a candle
company that's the guy
he makes candles he's a good dude he's
on Instagram is hanging over a candle
company LLC and he sent me these candles
he said he would know the people they
had these I'm gonna send you some you go
okay bro you gonna sue me something and
I haven't lit them yet so I thought
let's light each one individually you
know and then we'll see individually no
I'm just saying one like this one one at
a time yeah okay thank you Rick for like
being mister I have to like you know you
know just I'm here for an hour
pretending that you like me
all right Rick I do like you why would
you think I don't like you Jesus welcome
back to RIF and Ruth Griffith how you
doing my name is Rick glass do we go our
host you see this is what I'm talking
about move up yo move apart this place
is the size of my dick yeah that's good
so you can lean back cuz your lean back
er not everybody leans back you know
this is the Griffin I came for and this
is the Griffin I'm gay and that's the
Griffey that you need welcome back to
Richmond with Griffin my name's Rick
Glassman stop it stop it all right okay
choice number two down the drain no
you're gonna come you're not gonna come
on here take over my podcast did you do
the smell good it does oh it does smell
good huh yeah I feel like we're at a spa
well
this would be for you this would be the
worst spot ever for me the guy I saw
choking on a chicken bone under the
bridge gonna need a mean spot yeah when
I spa I I don't this is where I go you
don't really like yelling at you know I
go I spa you know I go to the Encore I
spend 180 bucks I like to do the same
thing you go to like I like to go to
Vegas yeah you have to go to Vegas just
for like you know good I get a steak
dinner I get this ball I'll go by myself
yeah like you're going with somebody all
the time if you're just going to the spa
so you go with someone then you leave
them because you want to go to the spa
how selfish is that yeah yeah you're
right you're right you're right Eric I'm
sorry but just for one night I'm saying
yeah yeah the spas are now everything
have to be a bit I'm just curious
I'm on your comedy podcast you coward
everything has to be a bit watch this
watch watch the views go down here I'm
gonna I'm gonna turn it off oh you think
- ninna cuz you know glass has got those
bit here's what I think I think when I
win an Emmy in 2021 people back 20 21
yeah when do we meet we met in 2010 no
yeah I don't think I think it was before
that we became friends in 2010 we have
someone with the carnies Carney's yeah
for the first time I think when Wow get
a one-on-one did we 2009 at the at the
earliest but it's obviously at the
Comedy Store
yeah we met at the Comedy Store in at
the Comedy Store you were handful back
then yeah you're not that you're not a
handful now sure it's still him still
are but I think it's more like one hand
instead of two no I think you're still
like like it's like if there's water in
your palm drinking from a stream yes you
know what I mean and I like before water
would just splosh right didn't do
anything with it yeah so now it's like
you know now it's like I only take what
I'm drinking but I'm still drinking from
like from my hands yeah yeah I've been
looking for that cup for a while and
with that welcome back
whispered with Griffin today our host is
Eric oh my god do you have a format to
this no judgment I don't have a format
for a mile he's just wandering it's just
called riffin with Griffin right so
that's what you know which is right up
your alley what you're doing right now
love a riff and welcome back Eric for
those of you who are not watching this
on YouTube um the set up is we're side
by side yeah which means not necessarily
that's why I had the things returned you
know what this is what I'm saying yes
what whole point of this is yeah you
could turn the mic you see thanks to
this yeah mute I don't know what God
actually I think it's my phone you know
what I mean
I don't know that's never happened
before I don't know what it is actually
I did something one time the last
episode I taped like Pauly Shore called
me you know and I was like what the hell
and then Rami Yusuf was on so like I had
to like I said it was probably sure
let's see what he said so I keep it in
the episode so you never know yeah you
know what dude I've been in this
business for a long time and one path
you know no I guess now where you for
you from are you from here from
Cleveland aren't you yeah but I was I
wanted to finish what my thought I want
to hear that story yeah you've been in
this business a long time continue with
the one thing is one thing I the one
thing I've learned is you never know
yeah so you're from Cleveland I'm from
Cleveland Ohio yeah you from Cleveland
and we'll put up a picture here of me
playing with LeBron James oh god are you
big you're you are a huge basketball fan
you still play basketball yeah still
pretty fit thank you
just say fit yeah I can say pretty fit
because it makes it seem like you're not
quite fit in a comedian fit for a
comedian you're in great shape for a
comedian you know for a rug salesman up
in a good shape yeah you're like like if
this is the WNBA you're like Candace
Parker of like good looks
you didn't mean but in regular Society I
don't know but yeah she's pretty yeah
yeah but for it to WNBA she's I think
all women are beautiful
no you don't you don't think that yeah
women just by design they're just you
know you you actually surprised me with
like like cuz you have your your quirky
guy you're awkward quirky guy you don't
I mean that's fine though back to the
clip would be with a mustache I love how
your brain works like you're always
editing that's hilarious
cuz you're sitting here and you're going
you're saying oh I know this is what
should happen in your podcast right now
in come some graphics this is some some
stats from Cleveland and this is me with
LeBron here's my mom's banking me your
parents put your parents never spanked
you there were a couple times dad
probably did [ __ ] you know as
punishment your mom and dad did a
vaudeville act there's like a punishment
I can totally see levy the coolest pair
by the way I love your parents your
parents are hilarious every time I see
them you know and I've watched a couple
episodes of like where your mom was on
you know I think that's nothing that's
great you know they're yeah I um my
parents are so [ __ ] my family is just so
funny and growing up I always thought
that parents are funny until I went to
college and MIT so might some people I
didn't know and it's like these other
people just regular people and then I
started to really appreciate how funny
they are but yeah my mom didn't didn't
hold to any punishments but my dad every
a couple of times lost it on me like
four times but did you need punishment
when you were a kid or like cuz i know
cuz you obviously you were like
obviously a little go ahead I mean you
know I don't want to get all your
business in the street but you got you
know you talk about whatever you want
quirky dude yeah I had some I had some
learning disabilities oh I don't like
the term learning disability I can still
work you're a very smart guy you learned
there's a difference between being
educated and being smart and one of the
UH I was I mean I still read
unbelievably slow I had a lot of
problems in school I think learning this
ability is important to recognize
whatever you want to call it because not
everybody learns the same
and to recognize that some people have
different obstacles and others are
important otherwise nothing's being
retained you know right okay I guess
that's a good way to put that I also
value value my what would be what are
called difficulties or obstacles that I
had as a kid because I otherwise I was
just an idiot
you know I'm getting in trouble all the
time and and getting bad grades and
really I'm a smart dude oh I guess I'm
I'm not
yeah you know I'm fulfilled potential
yeah which is most of us anyway yeah you
know you're doing great you have a you
have what is this closet and within it a
studio somebody made this for you
which we talked about before we started
this is so cool I know isn't that great
yeah how do you turn it on well I have
to take it off the wall and turn the
thing on I don't feel like doing that
and here's the remote control and it
ended changes to these cut different
colors but it's pretty great that
somebody took went out of their way to
make that I got to remember this
actually had the guy's name like right
here at all time so I could be like well
it's on the screen now God for me to get
an extra laugh from an editor Oh
oh my god you and your extra laughs with
your edits we have an interesting
relationship you and I well I would say
when I first met you you know like I
don't think you had your like whatever
it is you call it like in check yet or
even probably was aware that it was so
strong you know what I mean like I
remember you referred to it as me being
too eager yeah but it was well that's
one of the things yes for sure are you
just like you know that there's some
people that like are always on as a
comic and those are people that try too
hard and it's like it's just too much or
they're just like I gotta be funny you
know so then that was confused with you
know being whatever it is autistic or
whatever it is like that and you you
know you was just too much you know sure
you know and I just was like I can't
deal with this because it wasn't just
about you I had another another friend
like that who I won't mention that's
like you know in our comedy community
there was just like that when he was
young and I was like I can't
it just becomes overwhelming but then
like later
um I think whatever was going on in your
personal life for you you I think you
got a hold of like oh you know what
maybe I'm doing this you know I'm too
much and then you like you still don't
have it all under wraps because you know
good that would be like solving it or
not that it needs to be solved but it
would be like like whatever but you
changed or got our grips with it and so
now it's like then I realized you know
what I gotta be more compassionate to
people's situation and so then I think
that was the moment that we were able to
like actually become friends yeah
interestingly enough I always felt we
were but I do know what you're saying
and I recognize that being being friends
and wanting to hang out with somebody or
be around them is different from say
like yeah I got friends acquaintances
you got people that like oh I don't
dislike this person you know what for me
I I guess I I guess I understand what
you're saying but if I don't want to be
around someone they're not my friend
Oh got you you know I have I have people
in my life that that are my friends that
have what I think of his acquaintances
but like I kind of go get I gotta get
we're getting dinner tonight and blah
blah blah blah and and you I ask you'd
seems like you don't want to yeah but
you know he's nice and what are you
doing yeah but see the thing is I
learned a long time ago when I had a
friend of mine died that I realized I
have too many people that I'm
considering my friend and I don't want
to do that because because if I if I do
that then I'm gonna miss out on you know
like it's part of what the game is I'm
gonna pass the beats because you know if
we reference it every time it's just
fixing I don't think it's recording
actually I think it's like put him in in
post yeah I have to like you guys and
you know we're talking I was a little
email dig yeah yeah but I don't think
it's but anyways so I I was a kind of
guy I was like oh I have a lot of
friends I have a lot of people in my
life and I was trying to service all
these people I was like I go see this
person I gotta go see that person and
then you people fall through the cracks
and then when a person you consider like
you're really close to he just he died
tragically and I was like devastated by
it and I was like I realized oh you know
what the people that I really consider
my friends I got it I gotta tighten my
circle and there's an outer circle and
an outer circle but I gotta make sure
the ones in my inner circle that I'm
really servicing yes oh so you brought
it
kind of but people probably don't know
me or my situation at all and I was
diagnosed with autism a few years ago
and within that I have been exploring a
lot of my myself my lack of awareness
--is and learning new tools that are
more intuitive for more neurotypical
people and within a lot of these things
that I've been discovering a big part of
it is is energy and kind of like what
you were saying about always being on we
all have a moment of being on for me I
don't leave my house so I'm always home
and then when I leave and go do a show
here's my hour and a half you know be in
society yet and I got a few nos a which
which I still understand and feel
sometimes what I didn't understand was
how I was being received and in my head
it's a common symptom of autism is is
assuming that everybody thinks the way
that you think so I didn't know I'm
being funny so everyone knows I'm funny
and nobody was saying to me hey Rick I
like you but it's it's getting a little
much it's making me not want to be
around you instead what you were doing
is just just making jokes back but like
taking jabs at me and I think oh I have
a friend and what you're saying is I try
to tell this dude just shut up and he
didn't listen but within that I know but
that's why I felt like oh I better have
like a real conversation that's why I
was like you know what I got it like I
gotta be because it was like because I
felt something it was something
different like I'm always aware of like
like oh that guy's socially awkward or
this person you know III I don't label
it as like I wouldn't know I want to be
like he's probably artists oh he's got a
oz burgers or whatever you call it you
know I didn't want to be like oh it's
probably that but I felt like
something's going on so that's a cue to
me to be like well hey man
if something's up then like I have to
like check like how I'm being so if I'm
gonna be if I'm gonna be a monster every
time you're for you I gotta be like well
maybe it's best I not hang out with this
person because if that's rubbing me the
wrong way and it's bringing the worst
out of me then maybe it's best we part
or I have to also be like I gotta be
conscious of being like I gotta be nice
you know to this particular person extra
than everybody else
and some
that becomes you know if I'm being
honest that becomes annoying so I'd love
to talk about that and it's getting a
little serious now and also matter I got
caffeine in me so please be direct and
say Rick too many you talking too much
no no you're fine but I guessed Rick
Glassman everybody with our host today
is Eric Griffin I don't know if I said
that up front so usually say this is
will come great Glassman and I put your
name on this put the chyron up yeah
alright and we'll push it away so it's
interesting that you said that you you
know you got to make sure you be extra
nice and nice is an interesting term
that is defined differently for
everybody yeah yeah for sure some people
nice is when you go to a house party you
bring a glass of wine and you smile or a
glass imagine well here you go I'm just
here with my wine yeah don't you bring a
bottle for the house hey thanks for
having me
have a sip but don't drink it all to me
what nice is is sincerity and honesty
despite the fact that it might cause
some type of conflict and that's how
growth happens also how connection
happens when somebody's I want to give a
perfect example which is a microcosm of
what I'm talking about but this
literally happened to me I'm on a date
at to target with this girl that I just
met I don't say it like that because I
don't know if targets a date but
everything else was I picked her up by
the way you know what that's actually a
great date to do something normal with
someone's you see them in their
environment like going shopping with
somebody is like their guard there I'm
instantly vulnerable because you know
you can't fake like how you are at
Target you know you're not gonna go grab
like you know oh you know you're not
gonna be you know you're thinking of the
ordering the salad no you're gonna be
like oh I need this you get my whatever
so people are more vulnerable so I
needed a television oh wow okay since we
take you to buy it by the way just by
the way not to cut Rick off but I just
want to say Rick does very well with the
ladies you know I'll never forget in in
in New York you know you're opening for
me and you bring like what's-her-face
how you say your name I don't say your
name I'm sorry but she's just very
beautiful I was just I was like I did
like a triple take I was like god damn
this girl I'm looking at you thinking a
double take is enough
no no I had to triple it I was like this
boy look what you're worried about you
boom boom boom and she's like right in
front of me there was no need to double
take yeah she said anyway so you
probably had some beautiful chick at
Target buying her a TV I wasn't buying
her a TV you weren't okay I mean also I
can't do bits let's see that's how it
feels you know I respect your opinion I
don't quite understand the math on that
but sure of course you don't
so we walk in and I'm you know me and
I'm being hysterical yeah so you're
filming and she says she says Rick
you're being really loud I just met this
girl you know she Ricky being really
loud and and I said uh-oh
oh thanks and then I brought it down
uh-huh and which is a the reason is I've
started to value the information more
than I used to to where it kind of
supersedes the ego to where I don't
think I'm being loud I'm being hilarious
but I cannot tell you that you don't
think I'm being loud it's not a right or
wrong it's a matter of fact it's too
loud for you or it's too loud for your
comfort zone in Target in public with
somebody with meat whatever the the
thing is so I I now have been calibrated
to her expectations and her wants and
her safety right and that's the [ __ ]
that's nice to me it's nice for someone
to say it's this is too much for me as
opposed to saying you know as opposed to
doing this and me not noticing a face
that she makes or telling her friends
yeah tricks you know what Rick is really
cute and he's actually not even in
pretty good shape he's in really good
shape and not just for a comedian but
he's too loud and target and we push it
to the side so I think that when people
are direct yeah despite their uncomfort
of what they anticipate that we
appreciate that I need it it so much so
that I this is connected to this idea of
what friends are another thing I've
noticed is energy I love and when I was
younger I probably had more of it but I
definitely didn't recognize that energy
is finite and it replenishes you sleep
you get new energy you drink a call for
you get a little boost what
maybe but you literally logically need
to save it and use it efficiently and
energy isn't just about making jokes and
being silly or going for a run it's also
about emotional energy and listening to
people in dealing with people or having
allowing them to deal with you and being
around people that that some people are
more draining than others but being
around people that take your energy but
don't give you any mm-hmm it's just on a
logical level it just doesn't make sense
to be friends with them anymore
gotcha so if you see that girl again
yeah yeah I was gonna say cuz she sounds
like a good one cuz that's exactly what
that you would need I mean I am when
you're telling the story I appreciate
that this girl was like yo Rick you're
being too loud and then it's like you
calm down then you say okay good let's
go do this go do this now you know what
else was validating on what I said oh
thanks she laughed which I know that's
great you know I mean that's great so
she appreciated one that I heard her and
- my response to it and now I feel like
alright I'm in and I'm loud again ya
know I like that because I think that's
I think that's better than like like you
said she makes her face or she's like
just like in her mind like I can't wait
to get away from this guy yeah you
didn't even give you the opportunity by
just saying like hey I don't like this
do not do that and it's just most people
aren't built that way that's the sad
part about you know xiety it sucks it
sucks because we've all been taught how
to communicate in sorry good sorry
smell the candle it is it'll like the
other one in a second but let's just
well I just put this one we keep that
one for this episode okay yeah sorry
so we've been taught to communicate a
certain way and we've never really
questioned it because it's it's become
intuitive
yeah a big I've talked about this before
on my podcast but a big like a version
of this is the how you doin rule and
just like hey man how you doing good how
and just you say how you doing and then
you say good and then you say it back
and if you don't say it back you're not
a good person and also make sure that
you touch each other's palms and you hug
goodbye and all these things that are
not really connected and are necessary
but we don't really say what we're
feeling and we actually just took too
piggyback on this because I just to get
in the conversation is like when also we
go like hey hey Rick how you doing I
don't really care
yeah you go how you like you like ever
walk my people in your building hey man
how you doing hey how you doing and you
just keep going it's like sometimes like
I realize that I don't really want to
know so it's best to say something like
hello hey have a good day yeah I hope
you're well but when people say hey how
you doing because somebody might be like
actually I'm not doing well then you're
like what did I get into but I also want
to say something that I think that I
disagree with you on I think that we
we've learned these things but but we
were changed as young because kids I've
worked with kids kids would be we see
you know how people say kids are
[ __ ] because their kids are more
honest like if you're in a wheelchair I
kids the kind of person will come up be
like what's wrong with you what's wrong
with your foot terrible why are you like
that
I mean I think we were we're naturally
like that to me and you like to be like
hey what's up what's going on and then
we're told by adults don't do that yeah
I think we're sad the same thing yeah
but I'm just saying I think that we are
like what you were saying and then we
were it was taken away from us yes I
think the communication that we've
learned that is subconscious it's like
yeah is is being polite and this is what
I was talking about about what the
definition of nice and kind is and for
some it's having manners and for some
it's it's uh in my and they're not
mutually exclusive you should please and
I say I say Alexa what's the time and
then I say thank you you know like you
still have be nice but don't sacrifice
or what is truthful and what helps
growth by good things how are you you
know yeah one of my agents once said to
me we had a meet with like a meeting you
know the team of agents and you go into
like the room and before you know they
come in one at a time and the first one
was there he's like hey man how you
doing he was real connected I could tell
because his eyebrows went up and I said
good man how are you because I learned
at 30 to say that I used to be like I
don't don't or I would think for a
forever about what I had for lunch and
have to deal with it
so just felt so insecure because I
talked about this on stage now and my
example is lunch and I felt like I just
did a bit and that just soaking out of
it so let me get what doing a bit is
taking you out of it I feel like doing a
bit and pretending as if it's
conversational I feel is cheating no I
disagree
using a calculators fine but if you ask
me something and then I pretend I'm not
using the calculator it's like well you
had that tool anyway I hear you
it's trim the fat let me continue I see
said how you doing eyebrows up squinting
you know showing that his interest it's
a good man Harry how are you said good
man up thanks how are you and I said uh
I said good and he got cool cool man you
good and then and then we walk get
awkward and then for me I don't think he
realized it because he's being an agent
at the moment very good guy thanks for
everything being in a job and then we
could be doing better then he goes in
and then the other people come in and
they're like how you doing how you doing
how you doing how you doing and then he
goes hey man you good and I said you
asked me that three times yeah yeah at
the first one I thank you the second one
it's like okay maybe he's really
concerned about me the third one oh
you're not really connected yeah the
second one he wasn't really coming yeah
yeah I'm not gonna the first one would
you know that no no but you know that
now the third one I knew that then I
know you really you're just intuitive
like this guy doesn't really care it's
not about not caring it's about it's
about not being interested and the
intention behind it I care how you're
doing but I don't need to solicit the
information from you you'll tell me yeah
if I have something to tell you I'm not
gonna be like come on ask how I am if
you don't I mean it's just a platitude
and and that's this is genuine on your
part if you need to say something just
say it and I will always always do that
because there's this idea that we have
to open the door for Pete do you mind if
I use your bathroom I it's it's not
black and white you should still ask to
you someone's bathroom but what's the
intention behind it the intention is
saying hey I don't want to be a an
[ __ ] and I have to take a [ __ ] you
know what I mean what I think of it like
like like on text messages so let's say
I'm fine if I have a lot to tell you
I should check in first so I should be
like hey Rick can you talk yeah and then
you hit me back if you hit me back
you're gonna hit me back with how long
yeah what's up or whatever you're gonna
say then I could hit you with the
diatribe but I can't just open with that
and then get mad at you that you don't
respond
yeah that's texting is a completely
different ecosystem because you don't
have to respond right away I know but
what I'm saying though is like I don't
think you should open with it should be
like hey let me check in with you and
then I shouldn't get mad at you if you
don't respond to me right away we have
to like say I have to be like hey can
you talk right now if you text me back
right away yes then boom we can go yeah
I agree with that and because I could
take that even a step further mm-hmm if
we really truly get to a place where we
accept ourselves and what our boundaries
are and defining them it's so much
easier to understand that other people
have different ones right yeah yeah so
let's say you don't check in with me
let's say you just send me something and
I know that I can't deal with that at
the moment uh-huh there's no problems
here it's just what it is so I could get
back to you and say hey man I I see that
you're having a hard time I don't really
have the time at the moment if it's
super important call me otherwise let me
get back to you later yeah but that
would be considerate what I'm saying is
not everybody does that well that's the
point that's the moment I'm talking
about yeah but what I'm saying is agreed
what I'm saying is there's a again I've
said this on my podcast before but
communication should be the transfer of
information between a and B but what it
is is the manipulation of it and how
much it's manipulated differs from
person to person and from from idea idea
but like if I want to say something to
you hey Eric you're being loud instead
of saying that because I don't know how
you receive it there's respect there's
more efficient ways of doing which is a
man first of all I think you're
fantastic okay and I sometimes I'm too
loud at the moment and it's just like
all this extra information see I
wouldn't need that oh it sucks
people do it yeah I don't know I just
need hey but check the dude but he's so
loud but that's what I put the people
that do that
yeah need to receive it that way is what
I've learned now so so when somebody
talks to me like that even though I
don't need it I now clock oh this person
needs to receive things a certain way
mm-hmm it's just so much to calculate
man well for me I think that you're
missing something from communication
I mean to me communication is I say
something to you and part of that
communication is you processing it right
me waiting for you to process it you
answering me processing your answer and
then either agreeing or responding after
that I mean I think communication is way
more yeah that's where I struggle
because for me the processing is is uh
when I say faster I don't mean faster
than the average person I just mean the
way I receive things it I receive things
in a way where I'm hearing the
information before I hear the intention
and that that's something I've been
working a lot on yeah yeah and
recognizing that like data from it's
kind of like I was saying I value the
the information so much that it gets
past my ego which is a beautiful place
to live but not everybody's on that
frequency and I I don't pick up on that
into it and anyway I'm feeling myself
getting so Jewish I'm being so Jews
right now
Jew and then we push it off this guy
yeah do they do the Jew where it starts
as a dot and it comes up and I'm saying
you know talking about you not a key
that I hope you need all right let's go
back to this then so you're from
Cleveland yeah you know did you go to
high C's like the interview in like an
interview section right that you're
doing I just like getting information
for about people that I know that I is
why I like having my friends on the
podcast cuz I realize I don't know a lot
about them yeah we just work buddies you
know we've had some like that's some
great moments I've had more
heart-to-hearts as I consider you on
that that like that what you were
talking about not the inner circle but
like on that outer ring where where it's
any further aways and acquaintances yeah
you're gonna furthest away from a friend
but a Fred do you don't I mean
and I don't mean that based off of how
much I like [ __ ] whatever interactions
have been person that if I call
questioning about the parking you'll
give me a 45-minute runaround oh my god
but we've had we've had some good
heart-to-hearts and that's been Rick
Glassman everybody thank you Rick for
coming on don't you oh my god yeah for
the Edit yeah yeah wasn't that it just a
terrible there's something about being
sincere for a few minutes that when you
jump back in the deep end for a bit you
realize it's a little cold yeah you see
yeah and I I know how to live in like
I'm not on the border but I will say
that what you're about to start saying
is like yes I would like to say to you
personally you know publicly like this
is like when you told me about like the
autism and like the the level of it and
then things that were going on in your
life and that kind of stuff I really
touched me I really was like it made a
lot of sense to me it really did change
me in a way that I was like you know
what you don't know what's going on with
people I can't has just assumed that
like oh he's just an annoying comic
trying to be whatever whatever I'm like
no here's somebody actually dealing with
something really serious in an
environment that you have to be socially
interactive all the time and that just
made me be like wow and then like when
you were telling me about like how you
want to write the story about your life
but the one that really got me like you
know like I've been brought to tears a
couple times talking to you about these
things because it's like it's such a
like a beautiful story like a triumph of
like something that something that's so
like debilitating for some people you
know but like the met the best thing
that you like the one of the things I
stays with me all the time is about
about the teacher telling you hey Rick
it's you know go take your test
underneath the table you know so nobody
will disturb you and then you realizing
that your teacher told you that not for
you but for everyone else not just for
me not just for you yeah yeah so you
know in third grade my teacher just
ignore it
take another beep maybe you guys didn't
hear it I don't know but for us it's
like she had me take the test under the
desk and it's because I was so
distracted yeah
and I always remembered that of her
being kind of trying to find cheats for
help me yeah and I still think of that
as a kind thing but it was a shell yeah
I was a lot older and and connecting
patterns that were before then unrelated
that I realized she wasn't just making
sure I wasn't distracted she was also
making sure I wasn't distracting other
people yeah yeah and that was a big
realization for me of you know we all
are you know working on ourselves and we
all want to be the best version we can
be but while we're making the choices
that we are making and saying like this
is what I want this is what I want to do
I'm allowed to make I want to make
myself happy recognize if that ever
cannibalizes anybody else's happiness
and if I don't get a good grade then
that's on me but if I'm not getting in
the way of other people's grades I I
need to be put in check yeah yeah yeah
so yeah that like so so then going to
school in Cleveland and having this and
not knowing it yeah and there was
something going on everyone knew there
was I leave my parents yeah I was never
a bad kid quite the opposite um very
just connected and I just I always feel
it I mean who I'm telling you I was a
good person I just feel like I you know
I just I think if you go if you I don't
I don't have to qualify about this you
just weren't a troubled kid so it's
right I never got in trouble yeah for
like I never smoked a cigarette you know
what I mean I wasn't throwing eggs I
wasn't saying [ __ ] you mr. Tevin or
whatever yeah but yet I was always in
trouble for some type of behavior and
that made it harder probably for the
teacher to like cuz how do you qualify
like like he's not like burning the
school down but he's just a distraction
yeah and then it's like that makes a
teacher like think like but that's my
job is to deal with all the kids and
their things so Abe you probably made it
very difficult did for that T by your
nature and my my yeah um you know I was
diagnosed with different types of things
different medications I was in special
classes I was in like the learning
disabled classes and then I went to the
special learning sable classes I feel
like all schools have these it's kind of
like the basement there's the learning
sample study hall and then there's the
basement where the kids that twitch and
the kids that get into fights and like
the
you know the they walked you down and
there's like a iron gate multicam it
would be called learning-disabled and it
would just beat you know one kids you
know you know doesn't have parents and
all this and then there's me who has the
most loving parents I'm just and it's a
sitcom I actually think that's great
that's great you know I'm just singing
Mike for that you know learning-disabled
coming to Fox I'm thinking this more
like a Netflix oh it's a netflix okay um
we can get raw yeah so you could have
the real moments you know you need to
but what was I talking about
oh so and then and then in ninth grade I
ended up having to actually go to this
school this is a special school called
pep which is positive education program
and that was a school for what I thought
of at the time and I'm probably wrong
but I'm remembering my vision of it not
what it truly was which was like bad
kids like this is this is a move that
over there so it's not on you in our
class there was uh in every class as a
teacher and assistant teacher and a
restrainer o'j and the restrainer is for
when kids need to be held literally held
in get a bouncer in your class yeah
gomez oh wow look like you you look like
a Gomez that's that's what it is you
want me to hold you never wanna go Meza
hold me I never hold me Gomez I never
got restrained it but autism wasn't in
the medical journals until 93 meaning
that even when it was it wasn't very
completely understood even still it's
just starting to be understood and
accepted
I haven't often talked about autism
publicly because I have had experience
with people telling me that it isn't
real it is it true which I found myself
in positions where I was selling them on
this new identity I have for myself in a
way that doesn't make me feel good and
there's a there's a nice movement and
it's they have like a month for an April
and a day for it in April to autism
awareness month and people who were in
the puzzle piece pins and everything and
it's great but it's still a process of
people understanding what it truly is
and it's just the wiring of
how people I was gonna say can you
define it yourself what's your
definition of it the best I could define
it and I'll try to in a minute
but it would be what it is to me yeah
that's that's what I'm asking what is it
to you how would you explain like like
what is it to you and how does it feel
yeah okay well when I was a kid it was a
lot more difficult as I've gotten older
I've had I've learned new tools that
were come easier to other people and are
not as efficient so I kind of want to
qualify this first by saying I am NOT
defining autism and by any means and I'm
not I'm not a master of this I'm still
learning a lot about it right but what
it is to me through my experiences a lot
of what we've already touched on but as
a kid I didn't pick up on facial
expressions and it wasn't that I didn't
know what they meant as much as I didn't
recognize I was missing stuff got you
well just I just want to step in just so
I can like understand what you're saying
so when you say like you didn't
understand facial expressions I take
that as you mean to say that you didn't
realize you needed to calculate that
into the equation of the things that
they're also sorry for example like
sarcasm and yeah when it wasn't at that
black and white I picked up on stuff you
know it wasn't it wasn't I have no idea
but I would ask a lot of questions about
what stuff meant why are you why are you
doing like when I made that joke about
my agent I knew he was being sincere
because his eyebrows were up and II was
squinting that's a learned thing for me
oh I know that when people are doing
that they're either sincere or they're
feigning it I don't know what their
intention is but I know what they're
trying to have me receive so as a kid
I'm asking questions
non-stop annoying the hell out of people
gotcha
it also it could seem aggressive
sometimes IVA is there was uh when I
started to learn more about myself this
story is in that pocket so I'm talking
to a girl a friend of mine and she's
telling me this story and I'm not quite
connecting with her and I said what's
your point and she kind of explained
herself and wrapped it up and finished
in like 20 seconds I don't know what
happened but I did recognize she
some energy here when I said what's your
point there was an energy change and
here's where I'm starting realize okay
an energy changed it's because of me
what did I do all I did was say what's
your point
she must have received what's your point
a certain way I've learned that I come
off as aggressive sometimes so then I
was able to say to her I noticed that
you kind of wrapped your story up when I
said what's your point I think maybe you
felt I was being aggressive if so I
apologize but my intention was I don't
know really I'm not understanding what
you're saying yeah I needed to know this
thesis statement kind of just so I could
I'm interested just so I could follow
along she then said to me yes I did
think maybe you were just bored or
something my whole life I'm asking
questions I'm being aggressive I'm being
silly I'm being funny I'm really
interested I whatever whatever the thing
is that I'm doing was very often
misunderstood so the message was getting
lost into delivery and the biggest
problem with that or one of the biggest
problems for me was I didn't recognize
there was a disconnect so you could have
a misunderstanding with people and not
know what happened but at least you have
the question where if you're emotionally
mature enough and willing and and or the
other person is you could communicate
and calibrate to one another and then
learn how to communicate that well you
know we learn these things and the
things that work for us we continue to
do but until you recognize those
patterns you can't so me I'm saying
what's your point I'm doing bits I'm
asking why are you squinting meanwhile
people are maybe just think I'm making
fun of their face right so as a kid you
know human nature one of the one of
their biggest wants is to be understood
and I never felt misunderstood yet the
symptoms all existed I wasn't included I
didn't have friends I've told this is
what autism felt to you looking back as
a kid this was the concentrated version
of it I had a friend that I would call
every week to play for over a year and
every time I call him he'd have an
excuse
I can't I'm doing this I'm grounded ba
ba ba ba ba ba ba he never said Rikai I
don't want to play with you and if he
did then the next thing I would want to
know why he never said that so I just
kept calling him
for a year you know what I mean for a
year but by the way Rick this really has
nothing to do with like autism that I
think that like this is just you're
talking about someone with autism
dealing with a situation that everyone
deals with yes you know I mean you see
how did you deal with it like I don't
like I'm hearing this and I'm going like
I think this is the problem that a lot
of people have anyways so just like like
communicating like we don't we don't
know each other's language yeah you know
cuz you reminded me of southern you from
myself I had this III had the same kind
of thing this kid just didn't want to be
my friend anymore and it's hard to tell
somebody that much less tell somebody
with that you think has some kind of
social problem like if I'm your friend
and I think it's your awkward and I
don't know that it means I don't know
that it's autism but I just know that
you're weird just how a kid would be
Rick's weird I don't know how to tell a
weirdo right hey man I don't want to
hang out with you eat but even a regular
person you wouldn't want to tell a
regular person like not that you know
what I'm seeing like just sudden
whatever the norm is and you know
neurotypical is the PC term neurotypical
okay you you don't even want to tell
that person here hey I don't want to be
your friend and that's why it's
important to be able to pick up on cues
the unknown Bokan which I didn't and
couldn't so I never realized he doesn't
want to play with me I just thought he
was grounded every week yeah you know
leaves you took him at his word yeah I
believe and and that's just this guy's
getting in trouble that's yeah I mean
he's a bat maybe I shouldn't wanna be
friends with this kid if he's always
stealing but that's just one example of
all of these things about feeling like
I'm friends with everybody because this
isn't a TV show no one's dunk in my head
in toilets I'm not bully no one's being
mean to me and that's interesting I'm
kind of recognizing this in the moment
of how I define kindness they put
thought they were being nice and in
their way and their intention that they
were it's just the tools that we all had
at a moment that that's all we could use
but within that I'm I mean listen I I
had a few friends that I had or the
weird kids right I remember there was
one kid that I went to his house and I'm
censoring the name not that it matters
but I realized maybe don't where he
he loved camping but he couldn't camp so
he had a tent outside in his backyard
that we would stay and during the day
but you don't sleep in it because that's
technically camping and we would but we
microwaved some ores uh-huh okay the kid
was weird but he was nice and I felt he
doesn't have friends I'll play with him
you know I felt I was being nice how
where do you when the autistic kid is
like giving you sympathy
I didn't realize I'm one of them yeah
yeah I always thought I was being my mom
would always say you're so nice for
playing with this kid and this right um
I am that yeah because their parents are
saying the same thing saying this is so
nice and you had Rick come over to
microwave you know he's asking you why
you white squinting all the time but
listen throw a marshmallow for eight
seconds and then he'll leave you'll stay
in the tent for a little bit so I'm the
weird kid also as it as a kid I had
debilitating OCD and an OCD isn't isn't
uh does it make you aught istic but so
the autism digress for a second the
autism spectrum a lot of people think
how far along are you on the spectrum
that's not what the autism spectrum
means the autism spectrum is a spectrum
of symptoms it's a syndrome where you
give a little of this a lot of this
stuff and there's no science to
diagnosing it it's at a certain point
when there's enough things then it's
considered autistic right you and one of
a common one for a lot of people with
autism have OCD yeah as a kid I I mean
touching things a certain amount of time
I mean we all heard rituals I don't need
to explain what they were to me but they
were mine were I actually don't love
talking about him but there were things
that just going to do something ended up
being a 15-minute thing instead of just
going downstairs I had to go downstairs
a certain way or whatever it is so much
so that not only did it take so long I
also conditioned myself to avoid those
anxieties so I stopped doing things that
wouldn't make sense to do if somebody
touched me I'd have to touch him back
you have to be an even amount of things
which kept me away from being fit
literally close to certain people I
didn't
wasn't even a conscious thing I just
have now even removed just because I
can't and also I'm not present with them
because I'm just making sure that
they're if you're in your chair you're
not within range and if you turn oh God
and then when you did touch me I have
find ways of being like you know dude
that's funny touching you back instead
of just doing this and I'm calculating
how to survive instead of just being
present in a way and then and then the
outsider is seeing this as super weird
yeah and not telling me and it's not
their place it's it's not their place
that's why I think it's so kind of
people are direct because it's a charity
in a way you're going out of your way
to bring awareness to me yeah and that's
how is that received what frequencies
are you guys like for you that's
kindness not only is a kindness it's
necessary yeah yeah and and as a kid man
you like you said kids are we don't
they're honest also they don't have the
life experiences to be aware of what is
necessarily strange and this breaks the
mold this is just something that makes
this kid feel a certain way or this is
mean yeah and so to me the the big the
biggest part of it is is uh and this is
a pretty global statement that a lot of
people could connect to it's a lack of
awareness yeah the odd part is I felt
that I knew everything because I know
I'm so in touch with how I feel and why
I feel and what I feel and I'm assuming
that the other person feels the same way
so I know what you're feeling and I'm
wrong yeah you know as opposed to I'm
not sure what you're feeling and that's
a it's a small difference but it changes
everything cuz now I'm not checking in
I'm not asking questions
I'm not empathizing with things that
aren't clear to me and that's just could
be thought of as not as a good friend
you know I if you sat down you went I
either don't recognize you're not
feeling good or I'm thinking yeah my
stomach hurts too you know I mean and
I'm not checking in with you and I'm not
asking how you doing and all these
things build up that the reason you do
that is because just in case check-in so
let me ask you this that you'd like to
to keep it like going and know in the
direction that I wanted to go thank you
is that because no I get a sense of like
so this was difficult as you know
for you to deal with as a child this was
like it was a struggle to like always to
be present in all this so you go on
through high school you I thought you're
at the weird kid school you know what I
mean and then then when you finish it's
just high school was the pep of school
whatever you call it great so ninth
grade so that did you finish high school
there no I went back at the end of ninth
grade I was very embarrassed when kids
asked where I was oh you went back to
the back to the regular regular public
school yeah so now you're in public
school you graduate at that time it's so
your sophomore to senior year did you
have more tools to like oh so I started
playing basketball in tenth grade that
changed my life
yes I was gonna say that's great okay so
you're playing basketball yeah and I I'm
forced to be included because I'm
literally part of a team and with that
were forced to get to know each other
better and then I started to get some
friends is that the first time that you
find yourself like like cuz you you were
pretty good at basketball right I wasn't
yet oh no but I fell in love with it and
I without that seemed like that'd be
hectic too there but it's not about it
wasn't for me it wasn't about being good
for me it was about having a tribe and
having a team and confidence that people
want me to do well for their benefit
yeah and I want to do well for their
benefit and vice versa and your you know
cope but you didn't just get put on the
team though so III I almost said
auditioned I tried out in tenth grade my
friend Tim Gilmore shout out to Tim
Gilmore and thanks for changing my life
said hey man you play basketball and
that pep I'm playing a little bit cuz
you know they're bad kids so you know
we're playing ball right and I'm wearing
I'm wearing khakis with a zipper at the
knees you know what I mean I got the
button-down on it's way too big because
my arms are long I'm extra large Eddie
Bauer all day you know tell me he'll
figure because my mom kept telling me
how soft everything is god that's
another thing my mom my hope I don't
need to get into it but my mom would
always buy me stuff that I didn't want
like clothes because and I'd always say
I don't want it and she says you don't
understand it's so soft and I would say
okay I would always just say okay so I
always just had these these big button
downs and these khaki pants and I'm
playing ball and I'm one of the teachers
was wearing a ring and he hit me in the
face and
for my and I remember I went back to so
I'm in this special school in ninth
grade but I thought and most people
would make a lot of people in they go
there they're there the whole time like
you gotta like get out you know you
gotta like parole type of thing like I
first started going back I got out half
days let's see what he does and then I
got to do full but I thought to myself
I'm gonna get out ninth grade I want to
be in the yearbook even though I'm not
part of this school my mom let talk to
the whatever and let me go and take my
school pictures with my school so I went
and in that school picture there's a
picture of me with a big scar because I
just got hit in the face by a teacher
from you know prison ball but I'd played
ball a couple times and my friend said
you play basketball and what what I
think I heard was do you want friends
you know it was a translate yeah so I
said yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll play
basketball yeah I see he said you play
basketball I said I want friends it
could've been anything right you run
track-and-field you play soccer yeah you
want to do Dungeons and Dragons well I
was already playing a lot imagine
gathering at the time of course so you
were the one making the thing right you
were the guy behind the thing and then
the goblins come no that's dragons this
is our like dungeon area kids means
poker it's like an adult pokemons okay I
don't know anything about that was
beyond me
a lot I guarantee you a lot of your
gamer fans know about Magic the
Gathering okay well so so I started
playing ball and yet and I just it was
the first time I had confidence I felt
value and I got I got good at basketball
because in high school I think 10th
grade 11 I got okay I got my freshman
year at college is where I could say I
became like a good basketball player I
was like a year late pissed I would have
loved to have gone and like done dunks
and [ __ ] in front of the school but Rick
I I'm surprised that we've never talked
about this before I had the exact same
experience
I didn't start playing basketball till
10th grade yeah and like I was just I
went to a small high school I was - I
was one of the tallest guys in the high
school let's put up that picture you now
by the way cuz what a [ __ ] you enjoy
it's in the it's in the hallway - I was
like oh I mean I was in shape but anyway
just for a comic I was like an athlete
you know but I remember like I couldn't
play you know and I was like I
I'll never forget this the the the coach
was like really mean to me you know and
I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] show you
that's just how I was I'm still that way
you know if I always have to have
enemies you know I mean yeah I need you
but your shoulders yeah yeah yeah it
drives me I'm trying to work on that
also you could yeah okay what I should
because be a happy person but I've seen
some people that are like that my buddy
John Dewalt is like that and it's a
great tool it is a tool it is a tool you
know and it's like I remember being like
I've had this oh man it was going in
from my junior year to my senior year
okay so my junior year I'm playing
basketball I'm on the varsity team and I
shouldn't have been because I I just
started playing basketball you know this
is my second year and then like I was on
the bench and I'll never forget this it
was like the the the basketball the the
dinner at the end of the year with
they're giving out awards the coach says
you know and for like he made some joke
about like me sitting on the bench like
he made some joke and for like you know
for keeping the bench warm he thought he
was being funny you know he thought it
was a Terry Matthews as his name the
coach you know I've told him this too
you know he was a dick you know me but
he got the best out of me right but
anyways I never forget that I had to
like smile cuz everybody's laughing no
Eric's a good sport he could take this
you know what I mean
and I got my award and I left it on the
table and I left it there
uh-huh and I told I went home and I was
like I was like I gotta get better at
basketball and the new coach that was
coming in he said to me there was this
other kid in it that it was like a
sophomore we were all both gonna go to
the tryout for varsity you know and this
other than that the coach says to me who
do you thinks gonna start you or him and
he was being a dick about it
and I was like okay alright I went to
big man camp that summer mm-hmm you know
I said I found it I was like I gotta go
to big mankiewicz what state it was here
in California I was like I gotta go to
big man camp so then that was the first
time I found out that I wasn't all right
school yeah but I found that's the first
time cuz everybody's like what's up
little man you know me I was the same
you know I was like up 6-3 [ __ ] what
are you talking about but it was like
Russell Westbrook these ginormous guys
but I came back you know and I remember
that just this is just some early game
you know and I remember it was like it
was like the game was tied I was at the
free-throw line I got the ball and then
our best player was down on the post he
was being double-teamed and I was like
you know just pushing it on you it was
in slow motion by my rounds like [ __ ]
this I'm taking his shots and I took
this free-throw shot at it went in you
know and we won the game everybody's
going crazy you know I mean we're in the
bus and we're happy because last year we
were like we lost every single game and
this is our new coach and okay so
anyways we go through the year at that
particular time you got your name in the
paper if you scored 20 points you know
so like I remember the first time I did
that so I did it three games in a row
you know got my name in the paper so now
this coach who had been a dick to me is
we're preparing for this next team you
know and he's going down the line and
he's like all right the other team knows
what we got so they know your mall he
was our best player you know your mall
Anderson he lives out in San Diego great
dude get him on the pocket I got a do
but he was like because you're mall they
know he bought you mall they know bar
Harold and then it's me you know and he
looks at me and I'm standing there like
this Rick I'm I say I just want you to
say it you know in my mind I'm like just
say it I'm looking at him like it he
goes and Eric I could have quit like
that moment right there I could've been
like that's all I wanted by [ __ ] I'm
out you know I mean but I've got a lot
from that but I'm saying it's like
that's the moment I knew that oh I need
this like like this is how I'm gonna
survive and in comedy like Tommy at the
Comedy Store was that guy he was like
that guy that was like I thought I was
like oh this is a guy have to like yeah
I needed that kind of like you know
there are gatekeepers to our goals but
at times they become to our self-worth
as well which you know is day
if we let it happen no no we could drive
you but that kind of stuff drives me
yeah but people say you can't do
something or you can't like you know I
hear you on they don't I mean like I
don't know asked I'm still that way but
what I'm trying to do now is like find
ways to enjoy moments too though so it's
like if you win the game on Sunday
enjoy that win even Monday enjoy it but
Tuesday on now I can be like okay what's
the next thing but I have to I've been
taking moments just to be like I did
that that was fun
yeah now let me move on the the main
difference between you and me is when I
get that trophy
um loving it and I'm going home and I'm
putting that trophy up and I know it's a
joke true but I was to though I mean I I
was you talking about like when you got
the the certificate you would have loved
that certificate when he said
benchwarmer yeah yeah yeah I'm just
saying I love trophies I got you Eric I
love trophies so much I love tangible
things I could take with me when I would
go to our Cades but my dad would take my
brother and me to guys night out for
like a year we did that like once every
few weeks it was such great memories
with that we'd go to Randall Park Mall
we'd get corndogs and we'd go to the
arcade and they would go and play their
games and the only I would only play
games they gave you tickets or where you
could win a stuffed animal I guess I
needed I got and what I realized and I
think I talked to you about this at just
for last when we're on the roof once
when I was talking about this
under-the-table idea yes autism
awareness
I was cuz I was putting this in the
story what I realized is trophies kind
of represent something tangible for me
that can't change their mind does that
make sense yeah yeah yeah his kids would
be nice to me and I would be included
when it's a group and then I wasn't when
the group is smaller and I recognized
that but I never knew why and and and
when something that has my name on it or
a ticket or if I could put I would play
a game if you could put your initials in
as long as I could prove look at me love
like Donkey Kong you see that yeah it
was an accomplishment in a way that was
validating because it can't be erased I
mean it can but you know relatively
speaking okay here's the thing I don't
disagree with you and like I felt the
same way about those types of things to
what
saying this I was just more aware of how
messed up it was what this coach was
doing I understand yeah yeah like I was
aware of like oh this is actually cruel
like you don't understand like it and me
being realizing that I'm being
misunderstood like it like that I want
to be good at this right I wanted to be
good at this and like I felt like I
failed you know by him saying this about
me I felt like I feel I felt like oh I
didn't I didn't get the best out of
myself and I thought to myself you as a
coach you didn't push me and so I was
like [ __ ] I I don't want to be I don't
want to be remembered like this yeah
that was my thing I don't want to be
remembered like this I was like no I
have to I have to do something I have to
get better at this and then so like my
senior year I was all League and all you
know that kind of stuff you know I mean
it was like I was good it felt great
yeah you know even getting your name in
the paper at the time I had that feeling
that you're talking about just to be
like yeah you know that's me right there
you know I have like a picture of myself
from this like stupid Long Beach
[Laughter]
this is dumb Long Beach paper that said
something about you know you know you
know marry star we were playing that
that school we were dominating them but
I felt like I wish I was I wish my
senior year was my junior year because I
would like to have seen like having that
going into my senior year I always feel
like I'm a year late like I remember
going to the alumni games after that and
now I'm like [ __ ] I could dunk and all
this stuff and I'm like why didn't I do
this that's when I knew that what the
great players that's what I knew that's
why they were great is because it was
happening when it should happen yeah you
know what I mean yes sure yeah I know I
mean enough I took advantage of yeah
this is their circumstance allowed
things right at a certain time yeah yeah
two years out of high school I started
dunking days after our last game
literally days I did it in the gym and
then it was after school and I was this
I cause I wore khakis I always had I had
shorts on under my jeans and a cutoff on
under a t-shirt I would always just have
my gear ready and I was already wearing
basketball shoes
Garnett's that were just you know way
too big because I'm 150 pounds in the
size of 13 and I was able to dunk and
I remember liking it so much and wanting
everybody to see where I would go
because it's after school so most people
are gone but there's still people like
you know doing the extracurriculars or
some people waiting waiting to drive
home or whatever I went out into the
hall and I would wait for who I don't
care who it is teacher student and I
probably brought I did this by 8 or so
times I would come here I want to show
you something and people would come in
and they would see me dunk and they were
like that's cool you know and then they
leave bleeding I was bleeding because I
did it so much something happens when
dunk using an interesting thing because
it's really a lot of it is so mental
that once you could it's actually a
little bit poetic because once you could
visualize something you could at least
do it easier than if you couldn't and
once you have that muscle memory I was
eight once I did it once it's just oh
dude I remember first I know exactly
what you talked about because my school
again I'm tall right there's only a few
kids that you know you know like we was
talking in high school is oh man you
know at their playground lunch time I
remember the first time I I did that you
know and I was like it was just like
there's something about it you know and
that's why we used to go play it didn't
like the low rims those were fun times
we used to go play like the 8-foot rims
at the grammar school because then we
thought we were NBA players that was
just some of the funnest that's how I
tore my ACL I was like 26 at the dunk
rims and this guy anyway but the point
is I know for fun times you know yeah
but I remember that I know exactly the
feeling you're feeling you know and it's
like I never did you know my biggest
regret is I never did it in a game in a
and any not even a pickup game no no in
like at in high school yeah yeah and I
remember as I can literally tell you the
times that I am in my head today I'm so
mad at myself I started just a girl Greg
Rhett when I bet it in cops are doing
college I would to say daydream is to is
to not truly admit how much of a fantasy
yeah that I would picture not just the
dunk but the particular girls that I had
a crush on and the conversations but and
the way I would I fight your dunk Rick
the way I in the way I would be like
yeah yeah yeah you know and how I would
handle it yeah man and and just like
picturing because there would be my
senior year there was a frequently put
in glass
s-mint chance because you know I was
applying oh no we use the autistic kid
to hit six three-pointers and and I was
the autistic kid well people would be
crying we were a really good team we'd
like I said we played against LeBron a
couple years and and we had these
triplets on our team the chones triplets
and they were six six black kids 225
pounds I'm playing their position you
know I'm not getting in yeah yeah that's
first of all I'm not good yet and second
of all come on even if you were gonna
these guys are playing at Germany now
yeah so yeah I'm not playing and so I
used to I would fantasize about like
yeah you know what say put in glassman
and then put in there and then let me
dunk and then I'm picturing cuz that
there's you know all all high schools
have the five or six hardcore fans that
want to be part of the team yeah so they
like they were in the jerseys and
they're you know yeah they kind of
invite themselves in to like they live
for it yeah you know like they come to
the away games you know these people so
I'm picturing these people going nuts
for me it's just like it's so vivid like
it's crazy that we're talking about this
cuz it's so vivid in my head it's a fine
I literally remember like the play that
like afterwards I was like why didn't
you dunk man and then I you at my buddy
Harold gray okay we played together you
know and I remember we were we were at
this away game and I knew that like I
was aware that like I want to dunk the
ball and we had this fast-break like you
know he was like a little bit ahead of
me and like he was you know what it was
is he had 18 points and he wanting the
paper he wanted to get into the paper
Hey but if he would have given me that
ball I swear to god it would have been
the dunk of my life but I but the one
time I did try to dunk in a game was
like we were under the basket and it was
like oh they scrambled the balls and I
just grabbed the ball and I just know
why drop steps right I just I tried to
dunk the ball I got fouled and the ball
went flying up everywhere and I people
still go nuts in high school for that
though right listen especially cuz
everybody was like I was the dorky sort
of care that was just
you know and then it was like you know I
you know what happened I wish I have
footage of this I gotta find it
but it's actually I didn't get fouled
the ball just flew in the air and I
literally stopped playing because I
stopped I was in the middle of the game
and I was holding my shorts and I was
like I just tried to dunk the ball in a
game but the game is going on and then
my friend got fouled
but everybody was going crazy for me
they were like you mean better than the
two points it was better than the two
points but cuz but I was really like in
my senior I was coming into myself like
sort of confidence and things like that
because people were hard on me you know
okay they were really hard on me like
I'll never forget this it was like you
know that the dads were hard on me like
everybody I didn't know my dad and my
mom didn't even come to the games cuz
she was like did I think that I should
have invited her it's not that she
didn't want to come it was just like
whatever cuz she worked yeah I was only
a child she we single parent but these
dads and be like Oh Eric Eric you know
just [ __ ] you don't I mean so then the
one of my great moments is like I'm in
the post all the dads are sitting right
there and then like the guys on the
outsides got the ball he's looking and
then I posted the guy up and this is
what I said it's almost racist I looked
out and all the dads remember the
playing basketball that thrill of like
like scoring the ball achieving that net
one play at a time that was like I was
addicted to that I've been chasing that
my entire life you know but I find that
I get that in comedy yeah you know I get
that in comedy like making a crowd like
like I'm really laugh belly laugh or or
even making people uncomfortable or even
like whatever the thing that you do on
stage
I get that it's that same thrill being
good at something is is amazing yeah I
guess I didn't notice it's it's it's
what it is it's it's being valued yeah
yeah you know and we all could you know
we could we could be the most
self-assured person and have a high
sense of self-worth but to say that
validation from others doesn't mean
anything to you you lied to yourself
yeah I can't believe that yeah yeah you
know you can't it's not sustainable and
you can't you can't treat that as your
fuel right right but man when you when
you visualize something you execute it
and then other people notice it and
appreciate it it's I'm good at something
that's why that's why we do the things
that we're good at and it doesn't feel
like I play the piano right and I and
and I never looked at it as I practiced
two hours a day I'm just playing two
hours a day but when you're trying to
get good at something that you're not
good at when you're trying to when
you're studying for something you don't
understand I can't do this I don't want
to do this because you don't feel good
about yourself when you're doing it once
you start to see results I mean I'm
getting getting to spiritual into some
stuff no no this is great because this
is what don't know what you're saying is
like so important right now you're right
on it man so don't stop because like
like like people shouldn't people should
take that shot they should take that
effort they should make the effort to
try to be great at something if they
fall short that process of trying to do
that is is like a technique that you
should carry to the next thing and
that's that's good good to say in a nice
logical tool but until you've
experienced that and you can't empathize
with it I think we are kidding people
say you know you'll get this when you're
older and I believe I know what you're
saying but I don't know
now once I turned 30 and I can't play
ball outdoors anymore that's what you
know you can't empathize until you can
empathize yeah so I the the the
basically if you're doing something that
you want to do but you're not enjoying
it because you're not good at it you're
not supposed to be you know what I mean
you're not gonna be good at it and you
don't think I don't really believe that
but some things were better at than
other things but relatively speaking you
know when you first started you're a
funny person guarantee you your first
five years doing stand-up you don't want
to put that special out anymore
you know I mean because we get to a
different place and I don't even mean
you need to do something for years and
years I do believe that at least try
something for a couple weeks because in
a couple weeks if you get a little bit
better saying don't just give up what
I'm saying is if you will not great at
it right away you don't even have to be
great at it soon what I'm saying is I
believe my therapist hope my therapist
told me this once that it takes it takes
the brain two weeks to to adapt and
rewire and to give it a literal example
of that if you want an exit I want to
exercise and you go to it stuff you
don't know how to do it they're not
motivated do it when you go you you're
hurting yourself you don't feel like
you're getting results all the excuses
in the world they're real you will not
want to do it but do it for four days
what week one and week two by the end of
that second week your mind will be
conditioned differently a pattern now
and you'll feel something that maybe you
don't want to do but you will you will
see some results and we are addicted not
you and me human nature we want to lean
into what we're good at and when you
start to see results you see the thing a
little bit differently yeah instead of
oh I don't want to go anymore it becomes
I don't want to lose what I got yeah so
yeah well you know what on that and
we'll probably continue talking more on
Rick Glassman's podcast which is called
let me take your shoes off take your
shoes off so make sure you check that
podcast what's the one one more thing
backed on the autism thing that I could
feel like I talked about me more than
what the thing is I think a global
statement and this is bigger than autism
but it's spoken at least with this we'd
never know what the other person's
intentions are and to assume we do gets
in the way
there's a David Foster Wallace speech
that is beautiful it's 20 minutes long
if you think about just Google David
Foster Wallace what's it called a
graduation speech or whatever it's
called about whatever it is where he
talks about this in depth it's this
perspective of you never know what
people are going through so be kind but
it's kind of a literal explanation of
this but but the the thesis of that
there that I want to say is if there's a
misunderstanding if you don't like what
someone's doing you don't know their
intention the the
it's so easy to just ask them that so
everything I've said about lacking
awareness and not being included in blah
blah blah bigger than autism is it's all
because of a disconnect and I just
wanted to kind of sorry to cut you off
at the end I just wanted to go back out
there and say it's if it's a beautiful
place to be when you don't understand
something and you want to yes so and in
having questions and then having the
proper tools to autism I guess sometimes
gets in the way of of asking about or
the proper way to ask about hey well
howdy what is this what are you doing
you know and that's what you've learned
over the years you know in specific it's
it's recognizing that everybody receives
things differently not just the way I do
well I have a great example of that but
then we'll go is that like I was I don't
remember where I was but anyway this
guy's coming towards me I turn this guy
and he's got glass in his face and he's
bleeding and his hands are bleeding and
I say to him I go oh I go excuse me you
know he goes like this you don't see
like look at me and I was thinking to
myself I was like oh he he took that as
like I was trying to like hey man get
out of my way but I was I said excuse me
like oh I'm sorry I'm in your way mm-hmm
so in that little moment he was going
through all this thing right and I got
an even take the time to be like it
wasn't even it wasn't even proper for me
to be like but I was like had you just
let that one go I was like well I just a
dick at that moment but what happened I
don't know because he like you know I
wasn't gonna stick around
he was like it was like we were at like
a park or like it I know you're at a par
how was that like some kind of like I
don't remember where I was but I'll
never forget that like that was one of
those moments where I realized people
have miscommunication and it's not
always your fault and sometimes you
can't do [ __ ] about it it's also it's
some it's sometimes it's easier to see
the glass in someone's face then other
times when it's not as visible of what
oh that's a great place to end Rick
Glassman over here Rick Glassman my good
friend Rick Glassman right
I'll say that publicly and I don't know
we're gonna end up putting out at the
same time but Eric is gonna be on yeah
I'm gonna be on Rick's podcast which is
called take your shoes off you can click
right here if you want Jesus Christ you
can't click here it's gonna be at the
bottom okay it'll be there all the wicks
information will be there and once again
I want to thank everybody for listening
and subscribing and liking and sharing
and all that and I'm gonna kick I love
doing the content so I appreciate that
the love even the haters you know I take
something from that too and I want to
thank again Rick Glassman for being on
the show thank you very much for coming
out sir we had a great talk I'm gonna
have Rick on again because I think we
could continue with the conversation
about many things so once again this has
been Rick Glassman this is Eric Griffin
thank you for listening to riffing with
Griffin and Oh God okay good there's
actually music playing which you're
ruined but it's fine
oh I don't want to [ __ ] up melody yeah I
don't know what it is we're getting with
it if I get it
it's fine finish it off you know what
the mustache flailing and being able to
hear myself in this mm-hmm
I apologize and thank you for your
patience ooh there's something about
hearing yourself yeah with the effects
on it alright guys thanks for listening
to River Griffin you're gonna cut that
out like 20 seconds ago oh good night